let's talk about the big hollywood party
going down in palm springs january 6th
and of course hosted by the one and only
e.t icon mary hart we teamed up with the
palm springs international film awards
to kick off award season
[Music]
lady gaga is kicking off the new year as
the festival's icon award recipient it's
really just wonderful and a dream come
true she'll be joined by kristen stewart
whose transformation into princess die
earned her the spotlight award congrats
feel okay better than okay like very
okay
[Music]
let's not forget chairman's award
honoree jennifer hudson and nicole
kidman is receiving the career
achievement award her latest role is of
course lucille ball the grape scene was
very freeing and it was
so so funny still it holds up
timeless let's go show all of these
people will smith post this how it
started how it finished for king richard
that cast picks up the ensemble
performance award no matter what they
faced they faced it as a family and they
kept pushing it it's magnificent also
being honored to gala sponsored by
american express penelope cruz jamie
dornan in the belfast cast along with
director kenneth branagh and power of
the dog director jane campion andrew
garfield and jessica chastain will take
home the desert palm achievement awards
it's a party we're ready to party right
it is always a good time down in palm
springs and all the stars show up
you